STEVEN GRAY: I'm Steven Gray.
I am a post doctoral
researcher and a PhD candidate
at University College London.
I'm also a Google
Developer Expert.
Anyone know what Google
Developer Experts are?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
STEVEN GRAY: Yeah.
Great.
So Google Developer Experts
are basically developers.
I like to think of them as
the developer's developer.
When a developer doesn't have
an answer to a problem with one
of the Google stack,
they'll come to us
and we can answer the questions.
And if we can't
answer a question,
we know someone who can.
So I'm a Developer
Expert in Maps.
What's really handy is
there are Developer Experts
for all the different
products that Google has.
Here is the distribution
of GDEs worldwide.
There's 82 of them,
and as you see,
we actually are completely
and utterly worldwide.
We live here.
If you ever want to find
an expert for something,
developers.google.com/experts.
You can basically find
links to where we are.
That's basically
what an expert is.
We basically sit and we
interact with the developers.
We produce tutorials.
We produce all sorts
of handy content
to try and enthuse people
to actually use this stuff.
I'm Maps, so I really
like some maps.
So let's take in
a little history.
This is Google Maps
circa 2005, when
we had basically the UK sitting
there on its own and the US.
Great, isn't it?
Where's the rest of the world?
And then we fast
forward to today.
We've actually got the full
map, and actually, even better,
we've got Street View for a
high proportion of the world.
And what's interesting-- how
many people have seen maps
like this around the web?
How many people think
this is a good map?
Fantastic.
This is my pet
peeve in the world--
basically, maps
with lots of pins.
Google basically gave developers
skills to put pins on maps,
and everyone went
and put pins on maps.
One thing that really gets
me is putting data on maps
and making them
represent something
is really, really hard.
That's why I've still got a job.
So people may have
noticed-- actually,
let's do something better.
This is a true representation
of the Google Developer Experts
Map where you can actually
see, because all the pins were
actually on top of each
other over in Japan,
we actually have a higher
distribution of Japanese GDEs
than the rest of the world.
That's one way
maps can lie to us.
And the reason why
there's more GDEs in Japan
is that's where the
program started,
and so it's expanded
from Japan worldwide.
That's a really good example
of how a map can lie to you.
It's not just maps
that can lie to you.
Data can lie to you.
I'm a data scientist.
I deal with hundreds and
thousands and millions of rows
of data every single
day in my job,
and can everyone see what's
wrong with these graphs
by any chance?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
STEVEN GRAY: Apart
from [INAUDIBLE].
But basically, they have been
massaged to create a story.
Actually, if you look at the
distribution between the two,
the difference between
6 million and 7 million
isn't a gap of that size.
It's more like a
gap of that size
when you take the
access to zero.
So you can massage
data, and it's
the same with data on maps.
I said making maps is hard.
Can anyone spot the
mistakes in these maps?
Last time I checked,
London wasn't near Norfolk.
Cannes is not in Spain.
These are perfect examples
how it's really easy
to overlook maps and
actually have data lie to us.
So that's one of
things I try and do.
I try to make maps
easier to use and make
them more representative of
the data actually underneath.
Again, if you use
heat maps, you have
to watch for your heat maps,
because most heat maps actually
just show you
population density.
So a great XKCD.
Next thing you go
out and have a look,
see a map with a nice heat
map giving a story behind it,
go and check the population
density map first and see
if there's a correlation,
because nine times out of ten,
there probably is.
So back to what is my day job.
I work in a center called the
Center for Advanced Spatial
Analysis at UCL,
and we basically
build tools to make people make
developers put data onto maps
easier.
One of the products we built
on top of the Google stack
in Google Maps is MapTube,
which is a place to put maps.
You have some data,
you want to make a map,
you can suck it through this
system and we build a map.
So underneath everything,
what happens is
you have a descriptor to
decide what the data is,
and you have a style,
so you basically
decide what colors do you
want the map to look like.
You call it a couple of magical
lines of code, and what happens
is the system will ingest all
that data and, as if by magic,
give you out map
tiles on top of it.
It's a really simple system
to actually get data on maps,
and a really powerful
system called MapTube.
It's not just we sit on top of
the standard web Google Maps.
We actually built it
for mobile phones.
What's interesting enough, we
built it on Android and iOS,
but there were no libraries
when we came around
to actually doing this
on iOS, and it actually
took three months of my
take just one developer,
to actually put a single map
onto the mobile application.
Now, with some of the tools
that Google have made in the iOS
SDK, it takes four
lines of code.
Basically, my
three months of job
can now be replaced
by four lines of code.
And so we took this
premise, how can we
get people to put data onto
maps and visualize the maps more
interestingly than
just a pin in the map?
And we built this application
called SurveyMapper.
SurveyMapper allows
anybody to set up a survey,
distribute it to
the people that they
care about-- their
groups, their whatever,
or just give it out to the world
and ask people for responses.
And we build what's called a
chloropeth map, which is just
basically densities of different
answers in different areas.
This is a post
code map of the UK.
This map actually got
me into lots of trouble
because apparently
certain suppliers
don't like you to know what
your neighbors' broadband speeds
are, so that caused
a bit of controversy.
There was a little
academic institution
being told by the big boys,
can you take your map offline,
because we don't
want your neighbors
to know what speed
you're getting.
We had comments all
the way down in this,
which I've hidden,
where it was saying,
my neighbor has got 10
megabytes per second.
Why am I only getting two?
There was a whole
lot of arguments.
This is one of the
more controversial maps
that we made.
But interestingly, we're giving
the power out to the user
to allow them to set up a
survey and ask questions that
are interesting to them and
try and get the answers back.
I think we did good.
We've experimented, how
do we ask these questions?
We've used interfaces
like Xbox Kinect
to allow them to
slide the question
and that would answer
it for that location.
We've worked with museums and
we've worked with retail stores
to actually put these
kiosks in and allow people
to quickly answer
just by hand gestures.
They just wave at
the system, and then
they slide their answer, and
it puts it into SurveyMapper.
So we built these.
Behind the scenes, you
have all these tools just
to simplify actually
putting data onto maps.
We also built a
system called Gemma.
Gemma is a little
friendly gerbil.
Again, trying to make
it fun and interesting.
What we've done is we took
the power of Google Maps
and the Places API, which is a
way to get business addresses
and whatnot, and the data
from OpenStreetMap, which
is an open source version of
map data that we can access,
and fused them all together
into one system where
you can basically bring a
map together and print it out
for reports.
So for example, this
is the distribution
of bus stops in blue with
where people commute.
The layer hasn't come out
very well, but in the back
you have different
areas from the census
data of how people
[INAUDIBLE] commuting,
and the distribution
with their bus stop.
So again, we've fused this
together on top of Google Maps
to actually allow people
to print out these maps.
Also, we've put a
mobile aspect on it.
We identified very early a
lot of geography students
have to go out and
actually count things,
so we built a nice
phone app to allow
them to go out and count things.
They select what they're
wanting to count.
They get four little
boxes, or up to, I
think it's eight different
counting squares.
If you want to go
out and count cars,
you can represent each of them.
And that moves that
data straight up
into Fusion Tables, up
into Google Spreadsheets,
and then allows you
to have the data.
So you have that data.
The data belongs
to you, and then
you visualize it
back into Gemma.
Again, allowing people to go
out, collect the data that's
important to them, and collect
it in a group of people,
come back onto the
map and distribute it
via reports, PDFs,
whatever, or a nice web map.
Again, we do this using
the MapTube libraries
and a couple of
simple lines of code.
There goes a heat
map from what looks
like about two lines of code.
And actually, as of about four
weeks ago, that's now redundant
because Google now just
built a visualization library
to make it even simple
to make a heat map, which
was the original heat map
that I just showed you.
Again, you can build these
chloropeth maps really
easily just by giving a data
file and sending it back in.
So what's the point to all this?
One of the things about
collecting data and getting
data, my research at
university is looking at,
how do we collect data
on a massive scale?
I built this thing
called the Twitter Meter.
Twitter Meter basically
collects data from Twitter
and allows you to
collect the data
and basically try
and understand how
we use the city, how we use
the world through social media.
I built this in
about five minutes
as just a simple
visualization to see
what my single server was
doing when I wasn't looking
at it to make sure it was
still running because when
I originally built it,
it was a bit flaky.
It was going up and down.
It ended up being 16 dials using
Google visualization tools that
just basically sit and tell
me how many tweets per minute
are coming into the system.
Now, this is just for me.
I built this for
me and no one else.
It turns out that
people quite liked
the idea of turning digital
data into analog data,
so we built a couple
of meters that we
had spare in one of
my colleague's sheds.
We put it together
and we actually
made an analog version.
This ended up going into
the British Library.
The British Library
said, this is amazing.
Can we have it in our
Growing Knowledge exhibition?
We're like, yeah, sure.
It's just looking at my server.
It's just making sure that I'm
getting data from my research.
Why do you want that
in your exhibition?
And that was all right.
And then something
kind of crazy happened.
Basically, during
the Japanese tsunami,
CNN picked up-- don't
know if we can hear it--
but basically used it in their
reports for the whole thing.
So we went from something
that took five minutes to have
global exposure and was
used in a time of crisis.
It was really actually very
interesting because just
from the tweets, we could
see the actual distribution
of messages going from one
side of the ocean to the other.
For example, people were worried
about the tsunami wave going
to hit San Francisco,
so they were tweeting.
And when the wave came past
Honolulu, people in Hawaii
were like, we're
absolutely fine.
It's great.
Don't worry.
It's fine.
So you could actually
see the spikes
of data coming over
Honolulu and coming over
as the world woke up to
actually hear the news.
So that was something
where we took
a very simple virtualization,
but it had real impact,
and that's one thing that
I'm really engaged about.
But we had a big issue.
Once we got all this
media attention,
Stephen Fry, who
some of you might
know has 3, 4 million
followers, and Alyssa Milano,
basically tweeted us.
And we basically on our
severs got something
like 12 million hits in
the space of four or five
hours, which was
absolutely insane.
We had to very
carefully work out
how we're going to
keep our single server
in our academic covered.
It's basically manned
by me and my colleague.
How do we actually build?
So we had to actually
build a better system,
and this is where we went.
We went from a system where we
had one or two machines going
in that rack, and then we
scaled it up to the UCL system.
But then we found
the UCL system,
we have a bit of a problem.
We have to share it with other
researchers, unfortunately.
One thing you learn
about academics
very quickly is we
don't like to share,
so we had to think of a
better way of doing this.
We decided to scale it up again.
This is one of
Google's data centers
with their expert security
solution sitting there.
But basically, we
had to think of a way
of, how do we scale this up?
So we used Google Compute
Engine and the cloud
to basically fire up
machines to collect data
from all over the UK.
So what you have here
is each post code
data in the UK being served
by one compute engine, and one
component of code
that we have that
we wrote to collect this data
from social media networks
and fuse it together.
We tell it to run,
and you see it just
it spun up from the whole.
This is over 20 minutes
where we spun up
650 machines for
the whole of the UK,
and then collected
for a period of time--
I think it was two hours--
and then spun them down again.
We went from collecting
just from one machine
maybe 1.4 million Twitter
messages over a weekend
to actually having a
database of something
like 36 million tweets
over three hours.
So we basically had scaled
up very, very quickly
using the tools that you
developers can actually
use within the Google stack.
We did some visualizations, and
what's really interesting from
these visualizations from this
is you can actually tell from
the fusion of social
media-- so this is Facebook,
this is Google+, this is Twitter
data with a geospatial aspect
to it-- you can actually start
to see how we use the city.
If you look at the
top corner, that's
actually roadworks between
Rickmansworth and Wofford
for the period of time.
So people were sitting there
saying, why am I in traffic?
This is crazy.
We also did some really
great visualization
to prove that basically
people use their mobile phones
on the runway of
airports when they're
told to switch their
mobile phones off.
We've got concurrent
proof of that.
We can actually
show that on a map
where we've got a whole
concentration of data
of people tweeting
on the runway.
So unless people are actually
standing on the runway
tweeting, then we actually
know they're actually
using their phones.
We can use these
tools and these data
to actually tell a compelling
story of how we use our city.
That's me.
If you want to get in contact,
I'm Steven Gray on Google+,
and there's my website.
There you go.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]